now this is not how I died [ __ ] God all
that progress all that progress all that
running around all the progress just
[ __ ] gone
[ __ ] F this wouldn't have helped me
there cuz this is to Farmer close to the
other one God all the gods gone just
[ __ ] up in smoke I think I'm going a
different way than I went before
scp-1162-j you oh god [ __ ] I can't get a
goddamn break from you you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] off oh oh
[ __ ] really oh you [ __ ] I can't run
through this [ __ ] goop oh oh my god
oh my god oh my god just go away just go
away I don't know where I'm going oh my
god just do not get hit it oh oh you
Huk it's fine we're doing great we're
doing great we're doing great
we're doing great seven four one four so
oh that's new
um
okay
oh boy this
which way am I supposed to go in this
one
okay so it's just the it's the same big
swirly thing I didn't know that okay
you're right about here I think I'm safe
I know I'm supposed to go that way
oh that's why I kept getting whacked by
it because it comes back quickly you
have to go that one own no but yeah it
comes back there okay so if you're on
the right side there if you're right
here and you wait there and then you're
on the right side you should bypass you
there you go and then let me wait here
just in case it comes back and it would
would have hit me and then you fall down
and then is this out
am i out I'm out I'm out okay I'm out
can I clear up my vision please please
please okay I'm out and I'm in a new
place but in here there's a monitor
there's a monitor in there there is God
and of course I wouldn't have the right
clearance okay but we're hopefully near
a place where I could get something else
feel like I'm lot slower than I was oh
no wait but
oh [ __ ] I feel like I'm still running
like I'm in the oh god this is this is
where he got me okay this is a dangerous
thing this is a hole in the wall but
it's not good I should avoid it there's
nothing good about that I think not I
can't quite remember hole I can't
remember what it does and I don't have
time to read it right now because I
don't want to stand around to do nothing
let me just toss another one of the [ __ ]
ones that I already know about let's
move on
actually I'm gonna go back I'm gonna go
back save right here cuz at least I have
the note so that is progress I have the
note and that is progress I don't think
I don't think my character is okay after
that but you know at least I'm least I'm
not dead there is that okay so heavy
containment zone but I doubt this
actually goes oh no this is actually the
one that would work though I don't think
I wait wait this is open wait what oh no
I did I did run by here that's right I
ran through here so is there something
else no I don't I don't think there's
anything else over there then then over
here is where I want to be oh [ __ ]
that's right here oh okay
there we go hey buddy hey buddy hey
buddy hey hey buddy all right listen you
don't need to do nothing to me and I
ain't gonna do nothing to you no no no
no you stay right there okay
where's the goddamn button so I need to
go down here oh [ __ ]
really really really [ __ ] real I am
moving slower I am I'm still moving like
I'm in the other zone look at me with my
big waddle Ewok do not tell me my game
is just [ __ ] bugged now and I'm
walking like I'm in there the whole rest
of the goddamn game or maybe that's not
even a bug maybe that's just like how
the game is oh no I don't want to go
down there I don't need to go down there
oh no I'm injured that's it okay I'm
injured that's what it is okay
God okay so I'm injured I'm injured I'm
injured I'm injured that's fine so I'm
slower than I was which is why I didn't
back out of the Tesla gate at the rate I
thought I would okay but that makes
sense that makes sense yeah I don't know
what hurt me it's amazing that the the
the monster that started all this is no
longer the the like biggest baddest
monster okay I just got to be careful
with this one okay
close but I still made it okay I don't
think this is important
I don't think so anyway weird
what the [ __ ] whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
easy easy easy there God sometimes this
completely flips my camera around for no
reason for no reason oh there you are
again
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] prick
all right well that's scripted then so
then I can just go toss them in the
Tesla gate and be done with them piece
of garbage he's gone okay now we can go
down no problem um excuse me what was
that okay I'm guessing it's fine that's
probably fine I don't think there's
anything down here but I like being able
to see that just for my own sanity
I like the conformation that gives okay
I think it was to the right and
definitely not left that's real hard to
walk when I'm injured all I'm hoping for
is that once I get down there I get a
reprieve that they at least just leave
me alone for a little bit oh no wait no
this isn't right
you know it's one more down oh you
you're down here oh no oh oh oh you're
down here oh I didn't know that got so
hard to run
oh no no I'm lost
oh no oh good good good good good great
we're good okay
we should be fine we should be fine
okay
oh you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
okay all right good can't see [ __ ] okay
now what the [ __ ] okay 173 is nearby but
that's alright we can handle that I say
with nope why no what the [ __ ] why you
sack of [ __ ]
you are the goddamn worst you were just
a [ __ ] worst oh my god every [ __ ]
time no that goes nowhere but it has a
med kit that I need [ __ ] oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god which
way was not a dead end
I don't even oh okay well this [ __ ]
again okay I gotta go push the button or
I just gotta go for it okay here we go
here we go come on come on come on don't
[ __ ] me not this not this not this not
this not now
[Music]
I'm injured again like I'm double
injured the note isn't here anymore
so I don't know which way is the non
deadly route I'm bleeding out anyway it
doesn't matter I'm dead god [ __ ] damn
it
oh well that's new whatever god I'm
never gonna make it out in time like
that med kit is just outside but I'm not
gonna be dropped out there I'm gonna be
dropped in his little [ __ ] room
that's not where I want to be and I'm
just gonna die again good God boy hi Oh
what notice this No god [ __ ] damn it
oh I'm so mad what why is that here who
gives a [ __ ] about that no one cares
about that I'm just gonna die my visions
like I'm blurring out and bleeding out
anyway okay that's new that's new that's
new
okay it's fine it's fine it's fine it's
fine it's fine it's fine we're fine
we're fine
hurrah hurrah there it is okay
how's easier to find okay so I got a
count on the guy he's gonna be up there
I think it's like radical Larry Adam
Atticus pawns when he go down here for
the first time and then he the doctor
spawns up there when you go up there for
the first time so I just got to go up
and now I got to come right back down
I think that's how it is there's no
other way around it yeah so if I look
over here or not no it says they're real
close where are you Oh yep there he is
okay new at noon do I knew it okay he's
a-coming but now he is it not coming
okay
so but this is okay because in doing
this he D spawns and then so long as I
don't get cornered by him again
I should be okay big maybe on that one
big maybe but who knows big maybe you
still there still there big boy
okay all right it's okay so far all
right so I went one way and it did not
go well for me I think it was to the
right I'm gonna go left oh hey buddy oh
you're fine oh that's that was the
problem
Oh mother [ __ ] god [ __ ] damn it
that's I did go that way and it [ __ ] I
did the same damn thing that I did
before going like I think I went this
way last time
oh my now I'm gonna die cuz I'm injured
I'm bleeding out now there's no way out
of here
oh my god
where am I now
oh I'm in this hallway
[Applause]
that's that's different
oh wait no what whoa what what the [ __ ]
I'm back Oh what wait what what wait
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] wait hang on hang on a second
Oh God what do I hear what [ __ ] [ __ ]
every time I get an opportunity to do
good I [ __ ] it up any minute now there I
go yep cook plump let's remember to not
go that way this time how about that how
about how about that how about that how
about that remember to not do that how
about that
all right so going that way was a bad
idea
oddly enough going this way maybe not as
bad probably just as bad okay so the
maintenance this is where is where
there's a medkit there is a med get back
here there's a med kit I'm gonna use it
right away using it it's like no no
easing the pain slyly well I was hoping
you were gonna solve the pain problem
cuz that that would be great if you did
that no what the [ __ ] you [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ]
oh you at least I'm healed now so I'm
gonna [ __ ] well I'm going around you
like it oh I don't fear nothing you
piece of [ __ ]
oh yeah you're do not trying to harm me
okay just gotta run just gotta run just
gotta close these doors behind him oh
[ __ ] me go go go go go go go [ __ ] you oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god put the ring
back on
[ __ ] you you think you think you think
you think but you don't think I hate you
so much
Oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I can't give up I I can't I did like I'm
so close I think anyway I'm so close I
think I just need one landmark of
progress I have to have it like if I
don't have it then all of this was for
nothing
I've done nothing this entire time that
I've been doing this I've accomplished
nothing I've accomplished so much
nothing so my only objective now is I'm
going to get a card
I want a level-4 because I need to come
back and I need to put that in the
machine that's my only objective right
now I'm gonna get a card and I'm gonna
take it back to the machine that's the
only thing I want to do and that's the
only thing I'm gonna do so that's what
I'm gonna do so I need to get it and I
need to get back that's the only thing
it's down in scp-049 s area get it get
up get out that's the only objective
it's the only thing that matters right
now that's the only thing I'm gonna do
I'm gonna make sure I get it and get
back that's the only thing my objective
is to get back to the save point I was
just at that's what I have to do the one
that I just came out of that's where I'm
going back to
while you were close by me well that was
too close
I was too close that's all I gotta do
gotta get it get a get back cuz I can
turn that for I can turn that for into a
five and then an omni and then I've got
everything I need to go if I can get
that I will consider it a job well done
and then I'm giddy out of here I don't
hear him Oh what the [ __ ]
okay so there's 1 7 3 is in there I
heard you I heard you I heard you do not
[ __ ] with me do not [ __ ] with me don't
[ __ ] with me don't [ __ ] with me do not
[ __ ] with me ok
ok so this is gun it you're behind me I
know I know you are oh there you owe my
god you [ __ ] oh my god go oh [ __ ] go
go go go go don't [ __ ] around no [ __ ]
around to be done ok which way I need to
go okay I think a right and then that's
where the elevator is no that's not
that's not it
I'm gonna try left this is where it won
7-3 will spawn but that's okay cuz I
think behind it is what I need where's
the door where's it where's the [ __ ]
door
where's the [ __ ] door what the [ __ ]
her [ __ ] you a [ __ ] okay
I need to get around you I need to get
around ah no you [ __ ] move you
[ __ ] god [ __ ] dammit [ __ ] okay
it's fine it's fine
yeah it's fine it's fine
cuz it's fine it's fine
it is fine it is in fact fine it's fine
and it's fine
it's fine so what happened was this game
likes to be very selective of how
sensitive your mouse is it sometimes
will fling you really nilly across the
entirety of the camera when you don't
want it to you know how I'm like
sometimes like how did I get turned
around that's cuz the game just
sometimes is an extremely sensitive nice
thing other times it's like I'm winging
it back and forth it's not so much it's
very momentum based and I don't like it
but that's fine that's how I died
[ __ ] Mouse thing it's fine
I just gotta find that CP o49 just gotta
get down there and get back only thing
I'm gonna do the only thing I need to do
I heard Mr statue man I heard statue
that's fine he's not in here okay
so this is fine getting here has been
easier oh I hear the dude
here the dude where is he where's easy
ahead of me oh [ __ ] oh he's over there
are you in there
that's not where you should be um okay
left
I don't specifically remember
I think it's dead ahead I think it is
but I'm not a hundred percent what is
here no way no no no this is not it
that's right it's not this it's not here
that's right I keep I always go dead
ahead
there's nothing here right okay I always
go dead ahead but that's not right let
me try what's down here yeah this is not
it either
I don't think anyway unless it is no
it's not the right way okay that's not
the right way it's gotta be down here
then was it through these was it through
these these things I think it was wasn't
it
god I'm getting up yes yes yes yes yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah cuz it was yeah
here here here here here yes okay I'm
just gonna go for it I'm going for it
[ __ ] it [ __ ] you [ __ ] all y'all there's
nothing in here with me [ __ ] all y'all
I'm gonna grab it I'm getting the [ __ ]
outta and I'm goin home getting it giddy
outie going home okay so you need that
there I'm gonna just preemptively get
rid of that cuz I know I'm gonna find
the card if you're dead
okay you're dead no computer screens to
save in but that is a medkit that is a
medkit let me just go ahead and grab
that I'm gonna use that that's good
use this okay we got a med kit which
means that we could run okay med kit
taken switch it over to generator once I
get the elevator back up I'm actually
gonna go out the same elevator that I
came down I'm not gonna go back up the
opposite elevator I'm not looking I'm
not looking to make progress here I'm
just looking to get what I need to get
done okay there's the card okay this is
the card I need
grab that nope put it in there got it
there okay the question is how to get
around those guys cuz that's the real
trick here I gotta get around those guys
I think if I lead them through the loop
here maybe that would work well I think
that I got to assume that the Jade ring
is gonna do the exact same to them or
it's gonna protect me from them just the
same way as it protected me from okay
they're real slow but they're coming at
me the same pace I think I can ring
around the rosey them I'm pretty sure I
can ring around the rosey 'im you still
there very still be there
come on hey come on hey what are you
doing come on come on come on come on
come on bye come on come on yeah yeah
yeah come on come on okay ring around
the Rosie pocket full of what how the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you doing oh you
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh you [ __ ] ass you
[ __ ] oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] oh you
missed me by that much didn't ya oh you
[ __ ] did
yeah yeah I'm just gonna run to get some
goddamn space and I'm going back up the
way I came I got the card that's all I
wanted I got the card and I'm getting
the [ __ ] out here oh that's how you work
huh oh you sack of [ __ ] okay you command
me come and meet your [ __ ] [ __ ]
you are the cure you're the cure to
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know oh [ __ ] I'm gonna
run no don't [ __ ] dare do not [ __ ]
dare
don't [ __ ] dare if you did I would
have been unbelievably angry I got the
card I got it here I've got the card now
I just gotta get back in one piece
oh I blink Blanc tat the right time you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
okay all right where's the goddamn
button no no no that could not have been
closer that could not literally could
not have been any [ __ ] closer than it
just was that was the closest to death
I've ever been from Billy in the history
of the entire [ __ ] you what I [ __ ]
hate everything you stand for they're
really trying to get me huh they're
really trying to get me huh we're really
trying to get me but you're not going to
get me I'm bleeding I'm bleeding I'm
[ __ ] bleeding I'm [ __ ] bleeding
I'm bleeding I gotta go for where was
that med kit
where was the med kit where was the
[ __ ] med kit where was that [ __ ]
med kit
where was the med kit where wasn't that
good where it was the [ __ ] med kit
where where where where where what Smet
was it here was this it yes med kit was
down here I gotta do another med kit
which is [ __ ] but I'll do it okay
med get up oh hi okay managed to stop
the bleeding okay that's good
okay where are you guys you here you're
not here but I'm closing that just for
Billy's sake
okay here's the Bell room okay Bell room
that's fine come on let me out let me
out let me out let me out let me out let
go my god let me up okay
that Bell room down get through here
going down the I'm gonna die on the
Tesla gate if I die on the Tesla gate
I'm going to be there will be no saving
anyone that gets in my way if I die to
the Tesla gate there is going to be no
end to the amount of bitching that I
will do
wait is it was that the drip drop of
blood that better not it said I stopped
it said I stopped the bleeding it said I
stopped the bleeding
it said iced it said I [ __ ] stopped
the bleeding
why I just had to back into one of those
things again
no you up here I thought I heard him
okay okay that's fine
close it god [ __ ] close it I'm not
gonna get caught from behind that that
that [ __ ] thing that just I didn't
move my mouse at all I didn't move my
mouse at all that was just the game
deciding to dick just go just [ __ ] go
just [ __ ] go just [ __ ] go just go
just go
close this real quick sucking blink just
in case no Billy no Billy I don't like
that that's open I'm closing it just in
[ __ ] case
oh I did it
oh I did it I did it I [ __ ] did it
oh I did it I did it I did it I did it I
did it I did it I did it I saved
oh [ __ ] up I did it um which way is the
way to wait Larry's room maybe it would
have a medkit in Larry's room maybe
there would be him maybe there would be
a medkit in Larry's room maybe there
would be a medkit and Larry's room I've
got a level four now I can open it maybe
there would be a medkit in here I don't
think there is I don't remember there
being one but just in case
no but there's a level five
okay I'm not gonna save just yet just in
case it's um just in case there's a
problem with like the bleeding like like
if the bleeding does end up killing me
for some reason it's probably because I
was running immediately after I bandage
maybe there's like some mechanic I don't
feel like I see any drops of blood I
don't know why I'm going down here I'm
just kind of curious because I don't
really go down to the room much yeah I'm
not seeing any drops of blood I think I
think it's okay
I don't know why you would come down
here either
why do you come down here Oh
how did you get in here okay it's okay
if I die
yeah I don't
oh no tiny drop of blood that's okay
that's probably okay I don't know where
he is but if he kills me that's okay
because then I'll just go back to my
save but now I know there's no med kit
here okay what though what the [ __ ]
what why couldn't I get over that stare
I'm very confused I'm very confused but
I think it's okay weird okay yeah there
are tiny drops of blood okay I don't
remember
let's see
I just mean please
[Music]
okay I think that contains them pretty
well so he should be contained now so
Larry
shouldn't be a problem and I am NOT
dying which is a good thing oh well I
might die well you are a sack of [ __ ]
aren't you get out no no no no no no no
come on come on come on buddy you know
me it's your old pal
troll pal buddy it's buddy pal it's
buddy friend it's your friend buddy
listen buddy friend listen buddy I do
I'm never gonna get away from because I
don't have enough I don't have enough
[ __ ] I don't have enough stamina to
distance myself from before I would die
to to his touch he's just like right up
on my ass so this because yeah I can't
get away from him
like no matter what I do I'm not gonna
be able to get away from him cuz I can't
see this is why I didn't save this is
why I didn't save over there cuz [ __ ]
this [ __ ] that I'm dealing with
currently at my backside yes [ __ ]
what am I supposed to do about this
will you stop stop being an [ __ ] dude
dude personal space personal space
Versalles brace personal space you know
I think about it you ever heard of it
you ever heard of personal space no you
don't know what I'm talking about
all right whatever [ __ ] you okay it
doesn't matter
it's fine okay so now I know that he's
there I have the thing that I need I
know that I'm not gonna die so I just
need to take this thing over to the
Machine and I'm good to go
the machine is right here so I save it
right outside the machine I'll lock
myself in here I've got a level four and
there we have it so I think I just got
to put this level four in there on fine
and I think that'll get it I think it's
fine I think it's fine if it's not fine
I just saved so it's it's all good and
the safe right nearby so if this breaks
it into something that's not oh [ __ ]
hell then it's fine
hey level 5 okay
I think level 5 is all you need you
don't really need the Omni I don't think
you do the Omni I I'm pretty sure the
Omni is not absolutely necessary
I think level 5 is maybe maybe but I
don't want to risk it you know cuz I
have the 5 so I'm gonna go back i'ma
save and then the next thing I need to
worry about is just how in the hell I'm
going to get another med kit because I
still think that in the long run I'm
gonna need one more med kit I think I'm
just going dude
[Music]